l'ontarienne walton il y annonce un
printemps précoce fils son célèbre
cousin américaine nous dit aussi que les
branches bourgeonneront bientôt mais
fred la marmotte gaspésienne a vu son
nombre n est donc pas d'accord ce qui
est certain c'est que deux mois de
l'hiver météorologique sent déjà
derrière nous
selon environnement canada le québec a
connu en décembre des températures
relativement près des normales de saison
mais le mois de janvier nous a gratifiés
d'une météo fluctuante réchauffement
avec une souvent avec une tempête de
neige mais refroidissement en arrière
quelques jours de froid et le tour prend
sur une base quête quasi hebdomadaire on
est en plein coeur de l'hiver
au mois de février le froid semble
vouloir s'installer sur les prairies et
glisser vers l'ontario le nunavik et
certaines parties des maritimes
connaîtront des températures un peu plus
chaude que les normales le québec se
retrouve entre les deux est autant les
vagues de froid qu'une tempête de neige
même qu'un redoux il n'y a rien
d'exceptionnel
pourtant météomédia trouve cet hiver
bien particulier
il y avait quand même des points de
comparaison assez nette entre l'hiver
2015 qui était très froid univers en
dents de scie commencé très tôt en
novembre ils se déchaînent depuis le
mois de janvier
et c'est loin d'être terminé alors c'est
un grand cru cette année même sont
terminées pour univers un degré ou à un
degré et demi sous les normales ce ne
serait pas vraiment un hiver
qui passerait à l'histoire un terme de
froid entre les perceptions personnel
les prévisions météorologiques et les
prédictions des marmottes
il vaut mieux profiter des joies de
l'hiver tout en gardant sa pelle et ses
30 ans à portée de main ici au smic ryan
radio canada montréal